lefranc vit ses dernières heures jacques
chirac a tenu à saluer ce matin l'elysée
le vrai succès du passage à l'euro
une réception ferait à laquelle
assistait le ministre de l'économie
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
sortir de son rôle de candidat
alban nicosie leur unique s'intégrer
délicieux petits moments de cohabitation
consensuel ce matin à l'elysée il
s'agissait de célébrer le lancement
réussi de l'euro un formidable succès
selon jacques chirac obligé de saluer
publiquement
l'action en la matière du ministre des
finances laurent fabius y est monsieur
le ministre vous avez été beaucoup
sollicités pour le passage à l'euro et
des résultats sont là je connais votre
satisfaction et je tiens à vous
remercier de votre action ainsi que de
celle de tous les fonctionnaires
derrière les apparences courtois ce
président arbitre qui distribue bons et
mauvais points sans jamais citer lionel
jospin embarrasse le gouvernement après
les critiques sur la politique en
matière de santé
les compliments sur l'euro ne sont pas
dénués d'arrière pensées
félicité les acteurs pour l'occasion
même d'ailleurs dimanche à bercy
faire
éliminés l'euro sera donc fêté une
deuxième fois dans 48 heures un peu
comme ces enfants dont les parents
divorcés se disputent l'organisation du
plus bel anniversaire